france has announced it will withdraw
its troops from mali ending a nine-year
mission against islamist militants
relations between france and mali have
deteriorated since the ruling military
junta in bamako postponed elections and
announced it will stay in power for
another four years
french president emmanuel macron
justified the decision to pull out
we cannot remain militarily involved
alongside malian authorities with whom
we don't share a strategy or who have a
hidden agenda that's the situation we're
facing in mali
[Music]
french president emmanuel macron
speaking there and in a joint statement
together with its european partners in
canada france
france said anti-terror operations in
mali would cease by june the issue is
likely to dominate a rare summit between
the african union and the european union
in brussels today dw's jack parrack has
more on the strained relations between
france and mali
after a second military coup in may 2021
which followed one in august 2020 state
funerals like this conducted by the
military disguised the underlying
instability in mali
until now france has retained a military
presence of over 4 000 troops in the
sahel region but has long wanted to
reduce their numbers and especially to
move them out of the former french
colony of mali after the new coup
leaders expelled the french ambassador
since 2013 the european union has
provided a contingent of 1100 troops a
separate mission known as the eutm to
train mali's armed forces the european
commission says the plan remains to keep
the eu mission going for now the
situation of the utm for the moment are
there they are present in mali
our position is that we do want to stay
engaged in the sale we do want to stay
engaged in mali
having said that
not at any price from the european
perspective there's another military
complication the arrival of a thousand
mercenary soldiers of the russia-linked
wagner battalion in mali and recent
coups in bikini faso guinea and sudan
are all providing a less stable backdrop
with african leaders joining a rare
summit with the eu
the leaders of military coups won't be
attending the aue summit here in
brussels and while security is a crucial
issue on the table for the leaders this
is the first time they've got together
all together in this format since 2017
they wanted to talk about vaccines and
investment opportunities and they will
but the mali issue is likely to pull
focus
on the ground the people of mali are
also questioning european motives for
the troop deployments according to some
experts there is an understanding by the
population but also independent
observers that this is not the objective
is not security only or that this idea
this conceptualization of security is
also married with conceptualization
around migration management
on top of the european missions there's
also a un mission running concurrently
in mali the country hasn't really known
peace or stable self-governance in over
a decade
and for more on that we are now joined
by dalina gojo she's a researcher and
security expert on the sahel region
she's joining us uh from nyame in niger
as well as france canada and some other
countries are also withdrawing troops
from mali why and why now
there has been a breakdown in diplomatic
relations
which was due to the malian transition
government potential relations with
wagner group for example which now we
know
uh we seem to have
mandated timelines
sorry continue please sorry we had a
technical problem here yes i can hear
you now
all right um there was a reaction on the
part of the french foreign minister to
this and also the non-compliance with
the koa's mandated timelines for
elections post the second coup in mali
as you rightfully mentioned and finally
i believe the straw that broke the
camel's back was the expulsion of french
ambassador tamale and the growing
hostility from mali's new governing
military junta towards the danish
contingent of takuba so the fact that
the danes were sent back to copenhagen
meant that there was a very strong
reaction on the part of the french but
also of other european countries
so should we now consider the french
intervention in mali a nine-year mission
a failure
for containing
some of these armed insurgencies in the
tri-border area with niger burkina faso
we could say was not a failure it's the
stated objective of balkan was to
contain the level of violence and not to
allow armed groups to gain as much
territory or as much recruits as they
were possibly seeking to obtain but this
doesn't mean that it was a success
either
the number of killed civilians the
number of killed armed forces sahelian
armed forces um but also
minus ma present forces
and the number of displaced people
remains huge
i believe this is a difficult question
because we would need to see an
alternative reality with bakan
potentially never having intervened or
you know um
been subsequent to to serval in order to
tell whether it was better or worse to
have balkan there
so where does this all all these
withdrawals now leave the fight against
jihadism in mali and in the whole region
i believe there will be a vacuum of
security in the short term especially
for the guard the gender mari and the
armed forces of these three countries in
the tri-border area so there will be
problems in the short term
but this will also lead potentially to a
push for negotiations with some of these
armed groups notably notably um the the
al qaeda affiliated uh group in in the
tri-border area and
potentially the recruitment base for
these armed groups which have relied
quite a lot in terms of propaganda on
the presence of french and european
forces and this will perhaps
some of their recruitment base once
france and european canadian forces
leave
i think there will be also much more
reliance on our power um which presents
a number of risks a number of
significant risks for civilians given
what we have seen with the u.s
experience in places like afghanistan
somalia pakistan um but also mistakes
made
recently quite recently
in mali
delina gaucho a security expert on the
sahel region thank you very much
thank you
you